welcome back to new rock stars I'm
Hector Navaro and this is film ranks and
today we're getting
[Music]
done that's right folks get ready to
embark on a journey through the top five
dumbest plans in the MCU we had guests
Gina Epolito and Jordan Morris come in
to help us create this list after
locking ourselves in the breakroom the
three of us engaged in the kind of
debate you usually only find among a
council of nameless Scrolls only with
less name calling number five giving the
collect and infinity stone in Thor the
Dark
World I can assure
you it will
be absolutely saved
yeah in my
collection the dubious plan in question
no not the decision to make this movie
in the first place but rather something
from the post-credit scene that's right
intrusting an infinity stone to someone
who amounts to an Intergalactic hoarder
tanier ton AKA The Collector an object
of unimaginable power given to a
character even shadier than most of
bonio deloro characters and that's
saying something it is like giving your
drug dealer something to hold on to for
you it's one of the most powerful
objects in the universe The Collector is
notorious for his questionable
Acquisitions exotic tastes and an air of
uncertainty around him to hand over one
of the most powerful artifacts in the
universe to this character well that's
the kind of decision that even the
trickster god Loki might raise an
eyebrow at
I thought it was spot on number four
Doctor Strange wipes Spider-Man's
identity in Spider-Man no way home this
time our not so friendly neighborhood
sorcerer Dr Steven strange takes the
spotlight with a plan that leaves us
scratching our heads faster than Peter
Parker's web slinging acrobatics you see
Strange's ingenious idea was to cast a
spell to make the world forget that
Peter Parker is Spider-Man on the
surface it might seem like a sensible
solution to the webslinger identity
crisis but that's where the chaos ensues
now but my Aunt May should really know
Peter stop tampering with the spell when
she found out that I was Spider-Man it
was it was really messy and I don't
think that I could go through with that
again so my aunt me yes oh thank you
thank you happy no I'm annoyed the issue
here was a lack of clear guidelines and
parameters Strange's spell was like
trying to hurt cats at a firework show
chaos quickly became the order of the
day as villains from alternate
Dimensions popped in leaving us to
wonder if a pre-sell briefing might have
helped there was a whole debate about
whether it was even Steven strange
people are like that can't be him it's
too dumb it's either it's either he's
either too dumb or too evil it's a
classic example of a well-intentioned
but Hasty plann backfiring spectacularly
to be fair Doctor Strange did try to
warn Peter but alas it was a tad too
late the resulting Dimension hopping
villain fighting and Multiverse mixing
Extravaganza was a wild ride for sure
but also a solid reminder that in the
realm of superhero spells a little more
planning could have gone a long way
don't be mad at him to an an expert in
Magic and like can you do this thing and
the guy was like sure don't know the
rules don't you know the rules of magic
Peter stop messing with the spell tell
me what the parameters are tell Peter
what you're about to do man come on
you're the adult in the room number
three Nick Fury gives gravic the Harvest
we find ourselves deep within the
Intrigue of the Disney plus series
secret Invasion The Mastermind behind
this perplexing plan none other than the
ever cunning Nick Fury in an attempt to
outwit the Scrolls and gain their trust
Fury hands over the Harvest aka the DNA
of a bunch of super people to gravic one
of their leaders it might seem like a
master stroke of strategy but hang on
the Scrolls aren't exactly known for
their
trustworthiness I'm nothing but a
monster you see it's a bit of a heads
scratcher Fury's plan relied heavily on
trusting a shape-shifting alien who
already feels betrayed by Fury to think
that gravic was going to hold up his end
of the bargain was well a bit optimistic
we're not talking about being cautious
here we're talking about handing over a
potential GameChanger to an alien who
wants to take over Earth perhaps Fury
should have taken a refresher on
Intergalactic politics and even though
gravic is no longer alive Fury now has
to worry about keeping Gaia happy she's
very powerful just a quick friendly
reminder to like And subscribe to new
rock stars turn on those notifications
and please leave a comment
below one shot energy huh okay I'll try
it
oh
[Applause]
yeah whoa what does one shot's Focus
chew
do see
it
eternally whoa one shot really is all
you need begin your transformation with
oneshot energy today by going to oneshot
energy.com new rockstars for 10% off
your order number two Tony Stark creates
Ultron in Avengers Age of Ultron Stark's
idea was to build a suit of armor around
the world but here's the thing when it
comes to AI the track record in cinema
isn't exactly glowing it's almost a
universal truth that AI Creations tend
to have a knack for going rogue just ask
John Connor yeah that's a good point
they've seen terminat they have seen
terminate and they've seen Hot Tub Time
Machine too yet Stark didn't seem to get
the memo and the result was Ultron a
sentient AI with a penchant for world
domination maybe a little suspicion
about the outcome could have been
beneficial after all creating a highly
intelligent self-aware entity without a
fails saafe plan is like playing with
fire it's a classic case of Good
Intentions Paving the road to digital
damn Nation Ultron a sent to villain was
as predictable as well another stanlee
cameo in a Marvel film so Anthony Stark
we saw Salute Your genius and wit but
your plan to create Ultron was
undoubtedly one of the crowning
achievements in the mcu's annals of
questionable decisions that is
not the human race will have every
opportunity to improve now it's time for
honorable mentions before we get to
number one these are some other dumb
plans that didn't quite make our top
five in Captain America the First
Avenger we have the heads scratching
decision to put cap in a Uso show
instead of the front line why put a
super soldier in combat when you can put
him in a song and dance number instead
next we have Nicholas J Fury refusing to
call The Avengers in secret Invasion we
get being too proud to call for help but
just ask the Beatles sometimes it's okay
to get by with a Little Help from your
friends especially if you're facing
superpowered shape-shifting aliens come
on Nick and finally throwing it back to
the Incredible Hulk we have Bruce
Banner's heads scratching decision to
hide out in Rio de Janeiro really Bruce
Rio de Janeiro with its insane traffic
densely populated favellas and not to
mention Carnival that's like going to
trigger some anger it's
Carnival it's stressful and sexy
something tells us Banner didn't think
this one all the way through come on
Edward Norton now for the number one
dumbest plan in the MCU Thanos uses The
Infinity Gauntlet to kill everyone in
Avengers Infinity War you should have
gone for the
head in the grand tapestry of super
villainy there's Thanos a baddy with big
Ambitions and an even bigger plan in
Avengers Infinity War what was that plan
to eliminate half of all life in the
universe scientists have weighed in If
you eliminate half of all living things
on the planet yeah it doesn't work it
doesn't work like that now it's not that
we don't appreciate a good villainous
scheme but let's face it thanos's plan
was about as well conceived as Elon Musk
taking over Twitter boom roasted you
suck musk the Mad Titan believ that a
Galaxy wide genocide would somehow lead
to a paradise and all it took was the
flick of a wrist Thanos fancies himself
a gardener but the snap is like pruning
a rose bush with a chainsaw half the
universe vanquished in a puff of dust
and what was left chaos misery and
grieving Avengers it's almost like
Thanos never took a course in basic
problem solving Thanos may have been
right but his plan was horribly wrong
just make twice as many resources dude
you can do that and that is our top five
dumbest plans in the MCU this list as
promised will live on an infamy for an
eternity until the end of time is the
definitive authoritative list if you
want to see how we came up with these
rankings check out the film ranks
discussion on our break room Channel and
don't forget to leave a comment did we
forget any dumb plans do you feel our
ranking should be in a different order
let us know and maybe your moment will
make it into a future video for now this
has been this week's film ranks I'm
Hector Naro signing off to go formulate
my own dumb plan bye maybe I'll take
over Twitter
[Music]
good
m